things just continue to get worse
and worse and worse for republican
congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene who now in a
resurfaced video
resurfaced by punchbowl news's jake
sherman
publicly stated that she would oppose
the removal of hitler statues
hypothetical ones of course
so that she could tell her children the
importance
of hitler historically my guess
is that there are tons of videos of
marjorie taylor green
saying ridiculous and depraved and
horrible things that will be uncovered
in the future
remember that just in the last few weeks
videos of marjorie taylor green have
resurfaced
in which she shows up to the office of
alexandria ocasio-cortez
and yells things through the mail slot
in aoc's door
at her earlier this week a video of
marjorie taylor green
comparing wearing a mask on the house
floor
to the gassing of jews in the holocaust
was uh
uncovered back in march
marger marjorie taylor green ally uh oh
what was that guy's name i forget the
guy's name an
ally of marjorie taylor green was caught
on video
at the january 6th trump rise i don't
think this is going to stop
here's the latest video marjorie taylor
green
showed up at a dalton dalton georgia
city council meeting
in june of 2020. this was last year
after greene
finished first in the republican primary
but before the general election which
made her a congresswoman and she showed
up and she
specifically said she would fight
against the removal of hitler statues
check this out apparently the context in
general
is that she's against removing any
statues of
civil war figures or whoever else by
liberals naturally
and she says she would even be opposed
to removing statues of hitler
for you all um going into a runoff and
voting for me
i also want to say something else i
think
that this is a time where our nation is
being divided
and we shouldn't be we should be brought
together because
this is the greatest country in the
world and we
like the other man was saying about
breadcrumbs i don't think we should be
fighting about breadcrumbs
i think we should be working to come
together and work
further to keep things good and keep
peace
we're seeing situations where
christopher columbus
george washington abraham lincoln all
kinds of statues are being attacked
and it seems to be just a an effort
to take down history and whether
i see a statue that may be something
that i would fully disagree with like
adolf hitler maybe a statue of satan
himself
i would not want to say take it down
but again it's so that i could tell my
children and teach others
about who these people are what they did
and
and what they may be about so
as a congressional candidate i just
wanted to come forward and make a
statement
and thank you all for hearing everyone
in your community and also
let voters know where i stand on the
matter because i'm looking to work for
everyone here and i felt like it was
important for you to hear me
so thank you very much even a statue of
adolf hitler
or satan himself she would oppose
removing sort of a strange hill to die
on
i must say and at this point i want to
get back to the hitler statues thing
does anybody else think that marjorie
taylor green
has a sort of strange fixation on nazis
hitler and the holocaust non-existent
mandatory vaccinations
are like the holocaust she says
requiring
masks on the house floor at the house of
representatives
that's like the holocaust a hitler
statue
if someone wanted to remove it she would
fight against that
her reference to jewish jewish space
lasers
some months back there's something odd
here
and i don't know exactly what it is now
let's get to the concept of
you don't want to remove a hitler statue
so that you can teach your children
about world war ii imagine teaching
children
about world war ii and the holocaust in
class
showing a documentary film maybe you
invite one of the
increasingly few surviving holocaust
survivors to the class to talk to the
kids
and then you have to do a field trip to
the hitler statue so that the kids can
really learn about it like how does that
even pass the sniff test
how is that even a remotely acceptable
argument this entire
idea that you need a statue
to learn history or that it's even that
useful
in helping people learn history it's a
bizarre idea first of all
who learns history from statues i can
tell you as someone who
i went to school sometimes parents my
parents would talk about history
i would sometimes read books i don't
think i've learned any history from a
statue
it's almost like the write doesn't
realize that documentaries exist history
books exist
teachers exist the internet exists you
can pick up a book
and you can learn something it's that
simple and by the same logic
if she's fine with statues of figures
she support
supposedly uh or apparently hates she
claims to hate hitler
because of the historical significance
would she be okay with the statue of
like i don't know like a black lives
matter leader or something like if the
statue doesn't mean you endorse it
she should be in favor of it so that we
can learn about it right or something
it's just all completely incoherent as
we've come to expect from her
and the strange she seems to have two
primary fixations
alexandria ocasio-cortez she seems
obsessed with aoc
i don't know if she's obsessed with aoc
because she's jealous of aoc's
uh um sort of coalition and
the attention that aoc gets i don't know
what it is but she's obsessed with aoc
and then between jewish space lasers and
hitler statues
and masks are like the holocaust she
seems
obsessed with jewish related issues as
well let me know what you think
we'll have more about these strange
just video after video involving
marjorie taylor green
on our facebook page which you can find
at facebook.com
slash david pakman show we will take a
break
uh and much more upcoming today
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just 199
and you'll get 10 percent off all nebia
products when you go to nebia.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is right underneath this video